let me start by saying there's a lot I
want to talk about but I think my
favorite I want to talk right at the
beginning about my favorite moment which
is the beginning action set piece in the
desert I love that and it's not really a
spoiler but I love that I've always
wondered when people are in an action
shootout why more people don't go below
the car and shoot at people's legs yeah
and I'm like I watched this happen in
the movie and I'm like this is awesome
I've been waiting for this for forever
so you would do but I'm being serious
like you only see an apple above the car
and there's all that room yeah so where
did that idea come from in that sequence
it's probably it came from Julianne
Spencer he was he's an ex power and we
were previous in that sequence because
originally we were supposed to have four
days to shoot it and we ended up having
one day because the wigs got stuck in
Morocco and customs so he was like we
need to just we our whole take on the
movie was make it authentic make it real
so he said well in the Paris this is
exactly what I would do and it was to go
on I mean that was kind of a guideline
for a lot of situations I think you know
what would happen in real life
what do we do and both him and Jackie
well my characters based on they were
their clothes and kind of we just solved
situations it was a lot of emergency
kind of solutions cuz you know it was
kind of chaotic it was really warm and
and it was quite intense like the whole
shoot was quite intense yeah I mean that
was a 12-hour day in a very very hot
desert situation but we really wanted us
to feel that when we were saying what
Sam did that she could really do it we
wanted it to feel real so you could
connect to it as an audience and feel
that tension completely oh well done
great right and out no no I'm definitely
curious how did you two first meet and
what is it like when you're sitting down
for that first meeting thinking you
might want to work together you know are
you like nervous the night before are
you already thinking what you want to
talk about I mean I'm gonna let you cuz
how you knew what about me before we met
truly about you so I really was gunning
for new me and I was in LA
basically trying to get a meeting with
an agency so that I could get access to
her and I went in and did a pitch an
hour before my flight was due to go I've
been there two weeks and I only got the
meeting in that window and they loved
the pitch so they said well send it to
me and she reads quickly so then the
next I was like two days later I landed
in London and knew me he wanted to meet
so we met in off the Portobello Road
yeah
and was kind of like it was kind of like
love at first sight straightaway yeah
it's very rare that you really just
straightaway connect then you feel like
we are on the same frequency like we are
I kind of felt like I've been waiting
for you and I think you know we're
partners it feels like we started
building the character and and I went on
this journey together very much
yeah we shared the same vision yeah and
that took us the whole way through the
movie yeah and it's really exciting to
meet someone that has the same vision
for you or something because you know
then you're gonna create the movie you
want to create I'm definitely curious
from the genesis of the idea through
what people see on screen how much
changed along the way and how much
changes when you have an actor who's now
that character and in court you know has
that voice I think we kind of moved it
away from it was a bit more action II
before I was saying and when I came on
board I felt like kind of a whoa we went
into her it became stronger characters
and you studied you did your pass on the
script and it felt like we kind of
wanted to move away from everything
you've seen before as well to not be
repetitive other other films and
situations you've seen and and and I
feel like she I mean it's it's almost
like knowing me and some it's it's 50/50
you know right yeah well it was unique
because nearly came on both the projects
a year before we shot yeah and we really
worked on the script together so all
these layers that got added were very
much coming from new me as well which
for a director is a dream situation
because you're getting this real kind of
authentic fabric into the script and and
for me it was very important that it was
a female character in that role and that
it was uniquely a woman and therefore
it's not just it couldn't be played by a
man so the detail and the layers and the
to essential to achieving that really
yeah I'm also a big proponent of more
female more women kicking ass on screen
great so just you know I'm happy that
seem like you know but I definitely talk
about the editing room because
ultimately that's the final rewrite so
what did you learn after you're in the
editing room what did you learn from any
early screenings that impacted the
finished film um we screened it at a
point where we were actually already
quite comfortable with the structure of
the film I guess from the assembly
that's where we really learnt that the
film are two-faced the first part just
on the character so he left out all the
action and he built up the story between
Sam and Zoey and that gave us the real
fabric for the movie and then the action
was like a bonus because we felt and
this is what we learned I suppose
through the Edit that if you can engage
the audience with that character story
in that journey then the action becomes
way more relevant and way more enticing
and exciting because you're connected to
those those characters so and also like
I mean I think sometimes scenes are
overwritten it's so many too many words
you like you know and that was something
we started doing straight away to skip
things out like we don't need to say
that I can show it I can live it you
will see it in my body language just
kind of be less is more it's wrong is a
massively expression that so yeah new me
would say instead of these lines of
dialogue can I just show you yes do it
and you know and yeah that creates more
of a visual piece of [ __ ] yeah before
filming begins you're looking at the
script you know what you're gonna be
filming what's the sequence you're like
oh this is gonna be a pain in the ass
underwater and I was scared of water for
real yeah and how long did you have to
film underwater
[Music]
so when I started like I mean when I
went down with the divers first it was
it was a a journey for me to overcome my
fear because I hate being underwater and
this is I don't know I think I was
pushed in in a swimming pool when I was
like six or something I couldn't swim
and and ice it's like my body still
remember that kind of a fear in the shop
so it was I had nightmares underwater
scenes and it's a proper like it's a
fight scene I'm being like knocked out
on the water and and stuff like that so
it was that was my you remember do you
remember I felt like I was underwater
for like I think it was like I've been
on here for a minute
pitching Mike this is like 13 seconds
that was when we were practicing out
like what it must be more but he was
like it was interesting to to really
kind of look the fear in the eye and be
like okay enough I don't want to have
this anymore you need to like I need to
like fight is with myself and it was
very inspiring because you did not let
that fear stop you from doing the scene
they built a scaffolding tank so that
new me could get used to it well she
could stand up and then we were like we
can do it all at this level if you want
new me it's just like no I'm gonna you
know I'm committing I'm gonna do it the
way it needs to be done and you went
dear coming for that hook and everything
yeah yeah
have you gone swimming since then I mean
I'm okay with swimming like when I can
stand but um I don't like dark water and
definitely not being like held
underwater and fight on the water
absolute chris is big like he was this
giant guy yeah down yeah yeah I've seen
enough horror movies to know what
happens in the water so I read in the
press notes that you guys might work
again together so can you tease what
might be coming up well you have a few
things cooking we do a few things I
think a lot about authentic female
characters one of which is a true story
if we can save more than that I mean the
thing is we have a very strong
connection and I feel like we share the
same view on things and and we have I
mean next next one will be we will be
even stronger because we can be in a
stronger position but also I love I mean
you're a young filmmaker and and I am
just and very much in awe and admiring
your journey because I could see how you
grow and and she's it's quite rare that
you know she there was a it was a tough
shoot and I could see how you just like
reframed yourself and like took new
decisions based on the current situation
instead of holding on to like no no no
this is how I wanted to do this I've
been planning this for years you're very
you're very open to to whatever is in
front of you and make it work and it's
it's a it's a skill that is quite rare
so I'm very excited for the next chapter
we have together Mossad agent what that
note Congrats on the movie I hope you
guys are working together again soon a
fantastic day doing breast